Jeff what makes you so enthusiastic
about all things Greenlandic I don't
really know how I fell into it worried
but it was a place I in a relationship I
never expected to have and by virtue of
working with them when they were in New
phul and helping to build a shelter they
became my friends and and then I invited
them they invited me to Greenland and
they treated me like I was the king of
the world and then when they're here I
treat them like the most important
people in the world and over the years
we developed a lot of trust and and and
that's the big secret there so you know
I'm very protective of them and and I
look out for them and and I guess they
have a huge mutual respect and and they
asked my opinion and it matters and they
don't really care that I'm from
Newfoundland or from where else they
care that we have a skill set and
something to offer here that's and
that's how it feels yeah when you say
you built the shelter it is the
fiber-optic link that said that brought
you together how did you get involved in
that essentially it was phone call and I
was building the fiber optic links
around you for land and into nova scotia
and the Greenlandic government were
looking at coming here because of those
links that were put in and they were
told that I was the guy who was
designing this and as they called me and
initially they asked me you know if they
could find me a piece of land to land
the cable which we did and then they
asked if I could help them with the
landing of the cable which we did and
then they asked if I could you know
manage the design of this beautiful
building which we did and and then when
it was all over they asked if you know I
could look after her for them and which
I said absolutely so that became really
solid relationship and and to the point
where I'm the the Canadian
representative for a telegram land in
Canada and so that's where we are today
so what have you learned about the way
on the Greenlanders do business
Greenlanders are very
about business and it takes them a while
to warm up to you because you're going
to remember Greenland was a very
inventive i would say isolate a very
closed society and the opportunities
that existed were mostly inside the
island and now with opening up the
opportunities there they were trying to
figure out how they move outside and
deal with it so they're very much
learning and the thing about Greenlandic
people is that you know it's not about
telling people what to do it's about
share your experiences with us and let
us make our decisions let us learn about
the right ways and the wrong ways to do
but we want to partner with you and
learn together as opposed to just you
telling us how to do stuff so they're
very I guess they're like a sponge now
they're learning they very much want to
learn from New flan from canada from the
US and from from their traditional
paternalistic in denmark in europe what
are the opportunities you see for new
Flanders and Labrador ians in Greenland
in the way that it is opening itself up
for more mining offshore oil exploration
etc for me personally it the long-term
thing for me is I look at this cable
that we have between youthful and in
Greenland and it's a it's a digital
highway that we have between the two you
call it an umbilical cord I call it an
umbilical cord because really it's you
know we are physically connected by this
cable between green land and new file
and like we're connected and as well as
Iceland so the opportunity is what can
we do with this broadband facility and
at this point right here there is no one
between us and Greenland so the
fiber-optic networks that come in to
hear the bandwidth is immense and if we
can use that bandwidth for education for
health care you know how can we do that
how do we can support industry with that
bandwidth and that's for us to think
about and find out what makes sense
education is huge you know in terms of
the programs that we have here in the
backgrounds that we have in
during delivery of educational programs
you know green line right now is on the
verge of a huge I think my oil gas
industry you know we have the educate we
we were Greenland in the 1970s the
parallels are ominous and and we have
the lessons learned and that's what I
speak about when I speak at conferences
in Greenland here where the lessons
learned you know use our lessons and
apply them get ahead of the curve and so
we can we can do well in you know in
training we can do well in supporting
them you can dwell on supplying them you
know because this is our area we know
how to how to work in in the North
Atlantic and and the Greenlandic people
are very open to working with new for
lenders there's been groups down here
from Greenland that I have posted those
my new phone line is going back and
forth so right now we're at a
feeling-out stage so the oil and gas is
another huge opportunity you know the
mining industry is another there are
companies in Newfoundland have been
supplying mining equipment to Greenland
for years and I'm still discovering
those different things you know we used
to we used to move workers from new
flying to Greenland to work in gold
mines so it's all very much you know we
needed we need to look at what the
strategy is to do it as opposed to just
jumping at a specific thing but I'm very
optimistic I'm very passionate about it
I see the opportunities for Newfoundland
and and I'm working very tightly with
Noah and as well as the government a new
find the find it realizes opportunities
so what needs to happen now to actually
really get the ball rolling I mean do
you feel the ball is rolling we've got
the delegation coming here in February
from Greenland how do we build on the
relationships that have already been
started I think that this the thing what
happens in Greenland is people show up
and they look around and then they
realized that the business is not going
to happen right then and there and then
believe our thing is that we needed to
continue the dialogue it's not going to
happen overnight this is a near-term the
longer-term opportunity and we get a
look at what happened here it's going to
take a long time so by us interacting by
us
working with the educational
institutions with their government with
their employers association our
associations connecting together and by
doing that it will bring us into their
opportunity and as opposed to just us
showing up and saying where is it and I
don't ricci it right now so it's a
slower process and one that you know
it's just going to take some time to do
and I think that right now you know
there's a few people started the ball
rolling now people are getting more
interested there's a lot of back and
forth we just had to keep it up and
sustain it and we had to find that sweet
spot that we can provide value because
that's what's all about is finding the
best way to provide the Greenlandic
people with value we're not going to
replace the history between Denmark and
Greenland I mean those paternalistic
ties are huge the big thing for us is to
find out where new foal and can best add
value and stick to it and then kind of
put a fence in the ground and a post in
the ground and grow outwards from there
that's how I think the best way to go
and it leaders are emerging now like say
Noah is taking a huge leading role and
they're very passionate about leveraging
the experience that we have here in
certain areas so we've got the fiber
optic cable one other connections do we
need in order to build our relationship
and that's a good point that like the
fiber optic connector cable is a great
digital connection but we still this is
a physical world we still need to have
look at transportation links whether it
be shipping and whatever be here at Air
Lines and I've been advocating for
several years the ear routes between
youthful and in Greenland and not
because I don't want to get my elite
status flying air canada lose that but
but the the ability to supply people
whether it be for training and orissa
calling orlag ass industry and giving
the roots back and forth from just
normal trade or normal tourism and
transportation you know it's now is that
something you think a newfoundland
airline should provide or should be air
greenland I think you need to have the
dialogue with them to what makes sense
again this is going to be business case
driven but there's going to have to also
be I think some support to get it going
and some commitments on our side to be
able to put the people in the seats you
know if we have companies that are
working in the oil and gas sector in
Greenland we need to be able to get
those companies to use those seats to go
back and forth and vice versa and you
know green ivy people need to use those
that those seats to come here to train
to go to school to leverage our
infrastructure to travel and we need
that commitment and we may need to have
some some support from the both
governments to get it going in the
beginning but because it's been tried
before and it just didn't we didn't we
didn't or it just didn't take because I
guess the plan was too aggressive but I
think so start small and to grow will
build the connections and over time it
will make sense and Karen energy says
that we have to be competitive that
they're not going to favor Aberdeen
companies or Danish companies over
Newfoundland for their operations as
long as we're competitive how do we
become competitive need to understand we
need to make an apples-to-apples
comparison in terms of what the
competitiveness needs you know we need
to fully understand you know how Karen
defines competitive and you know that's
a job that knowing is going to now you
know we've met with Karen several times
and they've given us that message of
being competitive we think we're
competitive in some areas and in some
worries that we think we're competitive
ruian toll we may not be competitive so
we are now looking at how do we make
sure that we are absolutely competitive
and we have to earn that business with
care I mean it's not something that
they're going to give us because of
distance is something that we've got to
do our analysis and there might be some
areas that we probably aren't but we had
to work on them but I think knowing this
industry here that there are a lot of
amazing people working in the oil and
gas sector here and the products that we
have our world class and I know we are
competitive and and we're fighting to
show we are competitive because what
happens is if if you're an incumbent in
in Aberdeen and your supplier used to
supplying an incumbent you know land gas
company you know it's hard to break in
so we've got to find a way to break in
and then slowly when the trust of not
just Karen but the other operators who
are going to be drilling off the coast
and we had to earn it and we had to
package yourselves just proximity is not
going to win us the business but
couldn't that work for supplying the the
offshore rigs that they're going to have
their doing exploration next summer is
going to be quite a lot of real and
that's what we have to get our act
involved on and we are and we're working
really hard and it's great leadership at
NOAA and they're working great very hard
to make sure that we have the
competitive message and we had the
product that these companies want does
the promise need another port I don't
think it needs another port I and I
would I should I should defer that to
their right people at neue to answer
that question so I I don't have an
answer for that one right because if we
if we were going to supply we need you
know a lot more supply ships able to
come back and forth here yeah
intuitively you think that but I don't
know that's the case I I think that you
know the individuals down at the at the
Basin st. John's and babbles like they
would be probably better able to ask the
question but you know I can tell you the
very sharp people so what do you think
the future is of Newfoundland Greenland
relations I think that you know I think
it's going to be I'd say in five years
you will see a lot more education
focused in terms of us working with
green acted people and providing
educational services and a broad range
of things including the offshore I think
you'll see air links between and
possibly transportation or see links
between I think you'll see that youthful
and playing a major role in in that
because net the natural tendency is for
a new file and offshore to move to the
Arctic and we look very much further in
time and the greenland is a stepping
stone to the Arctic so I see us working
with Greenlandic people you know that
working together establishing you know
facilities together and then moving off
to the
Arctic and Newfoundland being the supply
base moving forward because this is
where the knowledge and expertise is the
way that Norway is to the to the north
see the new foal and will be to that
part of the Arctic I mean I'm convinced
that that that skill is here and that
that expertise will be leveraged into
the future what are the challenges we
have to overcome to get there the
biggest challenge we have right now is
you know making sure that you know we
are competitive and that we truly
understand what our value add is the oil
industry is all driven by value add and
we need to make sure that we find out
what we do best and that we sell it and
that people use it for their purposes
and then once you get in like you will
grow and will that move forward you know
it's it's you know we have a very
dynamic oil industry here and you know
we're going to sell our capabilities you
know we have a very dynamic mining
industry and we're going to sell our
capabilities as well as you know our
educational industry is very dynamic and
our experience with government I think
that a biggest challenge is it is to
keep you nourish you moving forward
people talk a lot you know is it in the
talk around things and turning talk into
action is the biggest thing and I'm
always an advocate for less let's do it
and hear all the right reasons and
that's a that's a great idea but we
can't do that whatever it takes
leadership in government takes
leadership in the oil and gas industry
it takes leadership in the mining
industry and we need to work together as
a cohesive team as opposed to everyone
doing their own thing and I think that's
starting to generate now and I'm very
excited to be a part of it what would
you say to a worker who now is looking
to you know northern Alberta as the the
future for you know his job or whatever
what what how would you compare the
opportunities in green line with Fort
McMurray I think that in you know it's
the oil and gas industry is like we're
not going to see activity in production
in Greenland for ten years it's from so
it's a long time I think that we're
never going to stop feeding
Alberta for resource and providing
resources there but for that individual
worker it's all about getting experience
you know in how they will again sooner
she works up there and getting a skill
and getting a trade and how can you
apply it back to those companies that
are going to be drilling up there in the
future you know we have resources that
are so experienced you know working
offshore that experience is golden and
you know that is what these companies
want they want to be able to have
executions certainty and you have
execution certainty you have have all
the right people with the right
materials and their word equipment in
the right place at the right time to be
successful and because drilling offshore
as we learn from the Gulf is very is
being watched and you don't want to make
a mistake while you're up there in terms
of job opportunities could Greenland be
the next Fort McMurray I not in the next
five years I don't think I think that if
the oil and gas industry takes off in
Greenland give you know the lessons
learned here in Newfoundland it could be
you know and it's not just all in guys
there's a lot it could be more it could
be you know there was a mining activity
going up as an iron ore mine being built
there there's the aluminium smelter
potentially that might happen there you
know where earth advert earth elements
you know you know new Philander's could
be with the direct air links new
fletchers could be supplying a lot of
people up there but not the next couple
of years but potentially ten years down
the road as production hits maybe a
gravity-based structure could be built
maybe not you know floating production
systems like over time like it may
happen but in the next 5-10 years is a
long way out from the gas perspective
right right okay thank you very much
you're very welcome